NOW BACK TO HANNITY.
>> SEAN: THE NEW LEADER, REALLY,
REAL SPEAKER IN CONGRESS,
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ IS
NOT RESONATING WELL WITH A LOT
OF VOTERS.
A NEW GOLF PUP POLL IS SHOWING
THAT ALTHOUGH SHE'S WELL KNOWN
SHE'S POLLING FAIRLY NEGATIVELY.
MAYBE IT COULD BE BECAUSE OF HER
RADICAL POLICIES.
SHE'S SAYING, IT ISN'T EASY
HAVING TO WORK ALL THE TIME.
IT'S SO HARD.
33 YEARS IN RADIO, 10 YEARS IN
CONSTRUCTION, 10 YEARS IN
RESTAURANTS.
SORRY SHE'S WORKING SO HARD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE THING THEY DON'T TELL YOU
ABOUT WORKING IN CONGRESS IS
THAT YOU DO WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO, YOU'RE WORKING ALL THE
TIME, WHICH MEANS THAT YOU HAVE
NO TIME TO LIKE SET UP YOUR LIFE
SO I SPENT WEEKS SLEEPING ON AN
AIR MATTRESS AND I DON'T EVEN A
CHAIR.
>> SEAN: FOLLOWING THE WHIRLWIND
OF BACKLASH AGAINST THE
CONGRESSWOMAN, IN THIS CASE,
ANTI
SEMITIC STATEMENTS, SHE WANTS TO
END A COLLEGE STUDY ABROAD
PROGRAM WITH ISRAEL.
WE REACHED OUT TO TALIB'S OFFICE
FOR COMMENT BUT SHE'S NOT
GETTING BACK TO US.
WITH REACTION TONIGHT, WE HAVE
FORMER CONGRESSMAN JASON CHAVEZ
AND PRESS SECRETARY FOR THE
TRUMP 2020 CAMPAIGN.
CONGRESSMAN, WE START WITH YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
YOUR REACTION.
NOT ONLY TO THIS, ALSO, TO THE
NEWS, WHAT WE KNOW SEE IN STEELE
TESTIMONY AND WHAT WE LEARNED IN
ORR'S TESTIMONY AND PAGE'S
TESTIMONY AND -- THIS IS NOW
BEGINNING TO CRUMBLE.
>> LOOK, THE FIX IS IN FROM THE
BEGINNING.
I WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
WE WERE TRYING TO DIG DEEP INTO
THIS.
WE WERE STONEWALLED.
WE WERE OBSTRUCTED.
THEY KEPT TELLING US, DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT.
THEN JAMES COMEY, ONCE HE MADE
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT, CAME AND
TESTIFIED BEFORE CONGRESS.
WENT LINE BY LINE, I'M TELLING
YOU, THERE ARE THINGS HE SAID
UNDER OATH THAT ARE FLAT-OUT
LIES THAT HAVE BEEN DISCREDITED.
MR. COMEY SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND PROSECUTED.
>> SEAN: WAIT A MINUTE.
HE SIGNED OFF ON THE FISA,
VERIFYING THE DOSSIER IS TRUE.
McCAIN, NO DOSSIER, NO FISA.
THEN HE'S TELLING TRUMP IT'S
UNVERIFIED A FEW MONTHS LATER.
DID HE LIE TO THE FISA JUDGES?
>> YES.
HE ALSO LIED TO THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE UNDER OATH WHEN HE
CAME AND TOLD US, IT WAS
UNANIMOUS.
IT WAS UNANIMOUS THAT WE DIDN'T
WANT TO CHARGE HER.
MEANWHILE, WE COME TO FIND OUT
IT WAS REALLY SOMEBODY PULLING
THE STRINGS AT THE DOJ AND THIS
IS WHERE CONGRESS NEEDS TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE, AND PEOPLE
HAVE TO KEEP DEMANDING TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
>> SEAN: NOW THAT WE KNOW LYNCH
WAS UP TO HER EYEBALLS IN
RIGGING THIS WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN
TO HER?
>> I DO BELIEVE THERE SHOULD
EITHER BE A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
PUT INTO PLACE TO LOOK AT THE
MALFEASANCE THAT WAS HAPPENING
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND WITHIN THE F.B.I.
I'VE BEEN CALLING FOR THAT FOR
MONTHS.
IF YOU CAN GO AFTER DONALD
TRUMP, THEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON, THE SENIOR MOST
ECHELON AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, AND THAT FAR EXCEEDS
ANYTHING THAT WAS EVEN AN
ALLEGATION IN THE TRUMP
SITUATION.
>> SEAN: KAILEE?
>> YEAH, THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, THE FIX WAS IN FROM
THE GET-GO.
WE LEARNED FROM LISA PAGE THIS
WEEK THAT, IN FACT, THERE WAS AN
INSURANCE POLICY AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE LEARNED THAT FROM PETER
STRZOK'S TEXT, VERIFIED BY LISA
PAGE'S TESTIMONY.
THIS IS STRIKING, CORRUPTION AT
THE HIGHEST ORDER.
WE HAVE TO STAND AGAINST IT AND
YOU COMPARE THAT TO THE WAY
HILLARY CLINTON HAS BEEN
TREATED, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS, A
HITCH WANT FROM THE BEGINNING
AND I WOULD ADD, WEISMAN ALSO
STEPPING DOWN FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL THIS WEEK, WHY WAS THIS
GUY THERE TO BEGIN WITH WHO COST
20,000 PEOPLE THEIR JOB AND
UNANIMOUSLY REBUKED BY THE
SUPREME COURT?
>> SEAN: CONGRESSMAN, WHERE IS
HOROWITZ?
WHERE IS HUBER, HE'S IN YOUR
HOME STATE?
WHY IS THIS TAKING SO LONG?
>> HOROWITZ IS THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
HE'S BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
NEARLY A YEAR.
I DO HAVE SOME BELIEF THAT IT
WILL TAKE ANOTHER MONTH OR TWO.
THEY BURIED HIM IN MORE THAN A
MILLION TYPES OF DOCUMENTS.
HE'LL BE THE KEY AUTHORITY ON.
THIS HE HAS LOOKED AT IT AND
SEEN IT MUCH FURTHER AND WIDER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
IT'S NEVER FAST ENOUGH, SEAN.
IT'S NEVER, EVER FAST ENOUGH.
HUBER, THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN UTAH
THAT WAS APPOINTED BY SESSIONS,
OVERLOOKED SOME OF THIS STUFF,
ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA WHAT HE'S
DOING, AND MOST CONCERNING, IS
THAT THE WITNESSES THAT WERE PUT
FORWARD BY MEADOWS AND JIM
JORDAN AND ENCOURAGING THEM TO
TALK, THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN TO AN
INTERVIEW.
>> SEAN: I'LL ASK THE SAME
QUESTION, ARE YOU CONFIDENT,
CALLIE, I THINK THE DAM NOW IS
BROKEN, AND WE'RE GOING TO THE
FISA APPLICATIONS AND GET THE
INFORMATION AND THE 302s, THE
FIVE BUCKETS THAT JOHN SOLOMON
ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE'RE GOING TO GET ALL OF THAT,
SEAN.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT AMERICA IS
WAKING UP TO THIS.
YOU'VE BEEN ON THIS FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING ON YOUR SHOW.
THE MUELLER REPORT IS ABOUT TO
COME OUT.
WE'LL FIND NO COLLUSION OR
WRONGDOING.
ZERO PROBABLE CAUSE TO OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE PRESIDENT
AFTER MILLIONS OF PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS WERE REVIEWED.
YOU WERE RIGHT ALL ALONG.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
THE F.B.I. AND THE DOJ UNDER
OBAMA.
>> SEAN: DO YOU BELIEVE, WITH
ALL WE NOW KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A CASCADE OF NEW INFORMING
IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD THAT
THOSE PEOPLE THAT TRIED, TO
FIRST RIGGED THE INVESTIGATION
INTO HILLARY, TRIED TO FIX A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IN THIS
COUNTRY AND RIGGED THE OUTCOME,
AND TRIED TO BLUDGEON THE WINNER
AND UNDO THAT ELECTION WITH
KNOWN LIES, THEY WERE WARNED,
WILL THEY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU,
YES, SEAN, IN MY HEART OF
HEARTS, I DON'T BELIEVE SO BUT I
THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
FIGURED IT OUT AND THAT'S WHY
HILLARY CLINTON IS NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> SEAN: SO THE PEOPLE THAT
RIGGED IT, WE NOW KNOW THEY
RIGGED THE INVESTIGATION, THEY
ARE GOING TO GET AWAY WITH THAT?
>> I WISH I COULD TELL YOU YES.
IF IT WAS UP TO YOU, ME,
RADCLIFF, YES, THEY WOULD BE IN
JAIL BUT THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT'S
GOING TO WORK.
THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WALK.
UNITE AS WELL SHRED THE
CONSTITUTION.
THERE IS NO EQUAL JUSTICE OR
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
IT DRIVES ME NUTS.
THAT'S WHY ON THIS NETWORK NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT TALKING ABOUT IT,
THAT'S WHY I WAS IN CONGRESS.
>> SEAN: YOU'RE DOING A GREAT
JOB.
>> THEY HAVE GOT TO PROSECUTE
THESE PEOPLE.